yesterday
Ellen Page well you know her as Ellen
Page she is now known as Elliott page
but Ellen Page was a great actress
Phoenix just told me he had a big crush
on her when she was in Inception she was
also in X-Men she was really really
great she was cute pretty fun she was in
a couple other movies she was just a
great actress
um she now is known as Elliott page and
I and I believe has had all the
according surgeries uh she she he
whatever went on The View and listened
to the way Joy Behar frames what's going
on with the Trans issue right now
especially because it's pride month uh
and then well just take a look
[Applause]
it's not a surprise to you that
Republican lawmakers across the country
are continues to introduce hundreds of
anti-trans bills that will ban gender
affirming health care for transgender
youth
I'm not sure what age they're talking
about under 18 I think yes under 18
right so why do you think the
transgender Community is being attacked
like this what is that about I mean it's
not like it's there 80 of the population
what's going on over there oh gosh
that's a big question I mean I think um
you know in many ways of course it's a
it's a political tool okay to to gain
votes it's to make people upset it's to
distract people from scare people scare
people real issues that are happening in
our society that do need to be addressed
and
and I think in and there's such a such
an inundation of lies and misinformation
like when you had the amazing
representative Zoe Zephyr on recently
when she was describing what gender
affirming for affirming care for youth
actually okay it's not gender affirming
care for youth once again if you chop
somebody's gender uh genitals off that's
not affirming their gender it's doing I
would say quite the opposite uh it's
worth noting that Jordan Peterson was
suspended on Twitter what about a year
ago for saying that Ellen Page or Elliot
page is a biological girl I then was
suspended on Twitter for pointing out
that Jordan Peterson was suspended on
Twitter for it so that that's why this
thing it's not just about the specifics
of okay this person dresses this way or
anything else it leaks into the rest of
society related to free speech and Tech
and almost everything else that is going
on in current events and culture and all
the things that we talk about here all
the time also did you notice you can
rewind the video if you want to see
later can we throw it back to it for one
second just liter give me like five
seconds of throwing back to it what's
with the little pride logo they have on
there where the word pride looks like
it's a Halloween logo what what are they
what is that what is that what I don't
know why are they celebrating this for a
month okay it's just it's all you get it
you get it you get it
[Music]
thank you